okay well we always love the way that
you tell it like it is so we came up
with a little game that we're hoping
you'll play with that's called state of
the union
oh oh yes i feel like i might be okay
with this all right all right we're
gonna ask you a few questions give us
your opinion
it's state of the union
[Applause]
okay on a scale of one to ten how hurt
were your feelings when kavya said that
your breasts dunk in this recent viral
video roll the tape so we can see what
we're talking about here
are you is that because my breath stinks
yeah
that's what you want to do
say
see i love that that's exactly what
you're talking about just keep it real
uh that would be a 10. i was like
i love you okay earlier in the drew's
news we discussed the tinder swindler
have you ever been swindled by
like a date
i would call that my first marriage
i am so in love with you i it hurts this
is why i love you god just ah
um okay the internet debate of 2022 is
are there more doors or wheels in the
world i hadn't heard about this but
apparently it's a huge internet debate
which one would you guess
i would probably go with wheels because
there's so many cars
yeah
i think the answer is that's really
probably one of the tamest debates going
on on our planet right now um what is
your take on the new uh spring 2022
trend now this is a fashion trend every
single runway show
uh just had full blown mini skirt action
everywhere now you rock the mini skirt
better than anybody what do you think of
the mini skirt trend in or out
oh in in
in
much to the older kids dismay they're
like can you please put some clothes on
um and i'm like no uh as long as these
things are sitting where they're sitting
on gravity hasn't completely taken hold
yeah you you really take good care of
yourself you you show us all you you
wear that miniskirt you earned
it i was just
i was just eating spicy tapatio pickles
and having a cocktail so i don't know if
i'm exactly always taking care of myself
but i'm still wearing the skirt
listen they say the key to life is
balance and anyone who keeps it too
straight is not my cup of tea all right
um and i want people who you know take
care of people and don't judge each
other and you are all of the things that
i hold sacrosanct in this world
gabrielle union i love you so much thank
you so much for coming on this show you
drink that line you do you we love you
cheaper by the dozen is available now on
disney plus it's such a fun movie get it
while it's hot
[Music]